Acme supports vertical decomposition by allowing any component or
connector to be represented by one or more lower level views.
Note that there are two things going on here. One is, levels of abstraction,
that is a view can be at a lower level representation of something of
a higher level. Also, is the fact that you can have multiple views of
the same higher level thing. Recall from our discussion of architectural views,
that no single view is likely to provide all the information we need.
And hence having multiple views, allows us to develop different representations,
that can each add something to our understanding. Each view in your
Acme description is called a representation. Within representation there's
a mapping between levels called a rep-map, short for representation map